l'acteur patrick de ware a boxé un
journaliste parce qu'il n'était pas
content de son article il s'estimait
trahi n'invente rien c'est aussi simple
que cela
bonjour à lui dimanche notre confrère
patrice du sac avait publié un article
sur patrick de where conséquences
quelques jours plus tard l'acteur sonne
à la porte du journaliste accompagné de
ce que l'on pourrait appeler de loubards
et l'envoie au tapis d'un coup de poing
dans la classe 8 ans régaler nous
l'expliquent week end agité dans le
landerneau du spectacle parce qu'il
s'estimait victime d'un abus de
confiance patrick gaubert a tenu à
rectifier lui même le contenu d'un
article publié dans le journal du
dimanche écrit par patrice de naussac le
papier en question d'après le comédien
aurait dû porter sur son dernier film le
mauvais fils et non sur sa vie privée
entre autres son mariage qui doit avoir
lieu demain suite à cette agression
patrice d'une secte qui a porté plainte
est-il affaire grave il est actuellement
en arrêt de travail pour 15 jours il a
sonné à ma porte et j'ai entendu une
voix douce patrice j'écris que ça comme
un jeu ouvert absolument sans méfiance
et j'ai vu patrick entrée dire tu
m'offres un verger pourquoi pas à ce
moment-là dont ils sont tous rentrés et
avant même que j'aie pu donner la
moindre explication
il m'a dit tu dois payer tu dois raquer
les coups commencent à pleuvoir je crois
qu'il a été choqué par l'exploitation
photographique c'est à dire nous allons
passer des photos de lui et de sa femme
mais des photos ne qui n'ont pas été
prises à son insu les photos d'archivés
datant du festival de cannes dont des
photos tout à fait officielle et donc
sont tout à fait des choses normales et
j'étais j'ai été très surpris de son
incursion chez moi de son expédition
punitive avec deux loubards de ses amis
pour me casser la gueule
le sel de l'histoire c'est que
dans l'article on peut lire qu'il m'a
déclaré je suis contre la violence
il a voulu il a voulu se faire un
journaliste qu il a trouvé ça très bien
mais je crois que c'est très grave
anglais parce que plus qu'un mouvement
de mauvaise humeur qu'on peut avoir
comme ça dans la rue en rencontrant
quelqu'un qui vous a déplu
il est venu chez moi c'est une agression
à domicile avec préméditation
pratiquement violation de domicile et
s'il suffit d'écrire un article qui
déplaisent pour qu'on vienne vous casser
la gueule chez vous je trouve que c'est
vraiment la très grave
patrick dewaere imprégné par son métier
at il trop tendance à jouer ce rôle
aussi bien sur l'écran que dans la vie
quotidienne c'est ce que pense pas
triste du sac
quant au comédien lui ne regrette pas
son geste la tranquillité de sa future
femme est en jeu
alors le shérif est bien décidé à
protéger sa vie privée
moi j'ai une femme qui si je pars je n'y
a qu'elle ne pas être malade vers un
hangar de journée ça leur merde est là
si un joueur est là à voir avec les
journaux ici on la nomme c'est pour être
ce qu'elle est elle est pour la femme de
2 vers toutes les 30 secondes je dirais
j'aimerais donc ça la regarde chez
précisé général ou coup j'en ai un foot
de julien cn et puis j'aurai j'ai juré
que je ferai mon possible pour la
protéger pas de regret de regarder ce
que les faits n'ont aucun aucun fait
elle faire c'est moi j'avais oui
j'espère que demain un gars des mois
mais ne sont pas dans le même état que
patrice de dussac pour avoir voulu
parler de cette affaire mais sans rire
il s'agit tout de même la dune d'un acte
que l'on peut considérer scandaleux
contre notre corporation